oh, well, if you're on the payroll it's easy to
say it works isn't it. But actually out there in
the real world there is not a European
demos there is not a European identity
Maybe. But maybe there may be one exception. There
may be one exception and that could be Belgium
because nobody ever dares tell the truth
about Belgium. Belgium is not a nation.
Belgium it's one of the most fascinating
countries in Europe. It's a country where some
of its biggest political parties are explicitly
anti-Belgium. Where parties of the same political
color are completely divided by virtue of language
and culture alone. A country where public funding
for political parties is some of the highest in
the EU, and it's a country where its political
divides serve as one of the strongest analogies
for the divisions facing europe as a whole.
Belgium is a federal state that has to constantly
struggle with balancing the dutch-speaking
flemings, the french-speaking wolons, and
also a smaller german-speaking minority. The
federal government distributes power between two
parliaments, a judiciary, and an executive branch
where language has to be accounted for at every
single step. The executive, the constitutional
court, and the chamber of representatives are
all equally or proportionally split between the
different language groups, and in Belgium national
parties do not exist they represent some ideology.
But what's more relevant is they're split by
language. When you examine below the federal
government all three language groups have
their own distinct unicameral legislatures
that each have their own executives and the
legitimacy of these communities is entirely
based on language. However what complicates
things is that there are also regions which
also have their own parliaments and executives,
and regions are not based on language and just
have more generic state powers like managementof public transport, the economy, and employment.
For example Flanders is a community a government
based off of a culture with its own common
language, but it is also a region with generic
state powers. In contrast, Brussels is a region
with its own specific economic policies but it
is not a community. Brussels has to balance both
a french and dutch-speaking population. Either wayregion or community in Belgium the divides they're
real on the federal level the two largest flemish
parties have been separated into the opposition
and regional governments are almost exclusively
culturally focused. The Flemish independence
movement is the largest party in the Flemish
regional government bar none, and the largest
political party in Wallonia, PS, is almost
exclusively Wallonian. In the media sector each
community has their own set of public platforms
be it radio television newspapers or magazines
In education where Flemish students are considered
some of the best in Europe with significantly
higher reading mathematics and science skills the,
Wallonian education system is below the european
average and in some cases french parents in
the Brussels region will send their children
to flemish schools as opposed to french-speaking
ones for that reason alone. In regards to politics
and economics Flanders is also often seen as a
creditor while Wallonia is often characterized
as a debtor and in the 21st century Flanders has
been typically closer to balancing its budget
and has also had less debt where Wallonia,
unfortunately, has had both a higher level of
debt while also controlling a significantly
lower share of national GDP and employment.
It's pretty standard knowledge among Europeans
that the distribution of power between the
Walloons and Flemings wasn't always this
way where Wallonia used to receive massive
amounts of revenue after the industrial
revolution through its steel industry
and Flanders was historically poor and had
a larger textile and agricultural sector
and was also subjugated by the french-speaking
elite this dynamic essentially flipped as the
Flemish city Antwerp grew in value as
a seaport in the early 20th century
also where socialist leading policies have
typically flourished in maloney and industrial
areas the Flemish countryside has overwhelmingly
voted more conservative and catholic
The biggest unions farmers organizations and also
health insurance and Flanders as catholic while
it is mainly state regulated in Wallonia this is
also visible in the flanders rural landscape where
houses are built seemingly random because for
years the catholic party incentivized laborers
that worked in industrialized cities to actually
remain in the countryside by constructing homes
in the middle of nowhere which is obviously very
expensive just for the sake of trying to prevent
Flemings from building a socialist identity in
industrialized cities today a Flemish independence
party is the largest party in Flanders although
the Flemish independence movement was historically
taboo the world wars allowed the Fermans to seduce
a section of the Flemish independence movement
by offering an independent Flemish nation within
the German Empire in World War 1 the Germans
who were occupying belgium conducted Flemish
politique and rule and divide exploiting a
fraction of the Flemish independence movement by
establishing the first Dutch university in Gent
and also by making the University of Gent dutch
speaking when Dutch wasn't even considered as a
potential option for a research language in 1968
at the University of Leuven Flemish students and
professors kicked out the french-speaking section
of its university while the French speakers built
new love in a french-speaking university 15
kilometers away in Wallonia since then state
reforms have been incremental but significant
very complex expensive and hard each giving more
responsibility to the regions and communities
and less to the Belgian federal government
take a northern western european country and
compare it with a southern one and you should be
able to make a couple of sound generalizations
about these countries just by looking at the
differences between the north and south of Belgium
like Belgium the North of Europe is more dependent
on services and trade and has recently had
a stronger economy while the south is more
dependent on industry tourism and is considered
by some metrics economically weaker being more
likely to suffer from economic shocks than its
northern counterparts like Belgium there is an
important difference which does matter between
Roman and Germanic culture and like Belgium
where consensus literally takes the longest on
the planet the eu also has extreme difficulty
with balancing European countries in order to
get even something close to unanimity finally
like Belgium, Europe is also uncertain about
what it's going to do with itself in the future